welcome to another spectator tv
us election special our final one before
election day
on tuesday are we in the dying days of
the trump presidency
or will he confound the pollsters and
the pundits as he did in 2016 and secure
four more years in the white house we'll
be talking to one of the very few
posters who thinks that donald trump
is likely to win we'll have another
analysis of the state of the race
who discuss the early voting factor
about 70 million americans
have already voted and will explain what
to look for
on election night it could be the most
complicated and drawn out ever
and we have a u.s election special offer
for you to subscribe to the spectator
go to spectator dot co dot u k slash
vote subscribe for just a
pound a week a mere pound a week to get
the spectator
and once you're there you can select the
man mr biden or mr trump
that you think will be the next
president if you're right
and you have a 50 50 chance of being
right
a 30 pound amazon gift voucher will be
on its way to you
after the election and we know the
result on some scenarios
it means you might not get that voucher
until about january the 10th
but we'll see on this u.s election
edition special for spectator tv
patrick basham director of the democracy
institute a
politically independent public policy
research organization
based in washington and london jacob
hilbrum
editor of the national interest the
spectator's contributing editor douglas
murray
the spectators economics correspondent
kate andrews
and the spectator's u.s editor freddie
gray
now patrick let me come to you your
institute has done
some can i call it quite seriously
unusual polling that suggests donald
trump is going to win
perhaps even when easily understand can
you take us through
some of your slides explain why and
explain your
different methodology patrick yeah here
are a few of our numbers
and they give you a flavor of where we
think the race is we have a final poll
coming out this weekend but our most
recent numbers are these
uh we have donald trump national popular
vote
up by one point over joe biden and that
means it's within the margin of error
it's basically
tied as a national race but so that's
encouraging obviously for trump and goes
against the grain of most polls
but if you look at our next slide which
is the battleground
states we have consistently over the
last five months of polling
shown donald trump with a modest
but comfortable lead in the battleground
states what this demonstrates is that as
in 2016 his vote is far more efficient
than his democratic opponent so he could
once again lose the popular vote
but win the electoral college by winning
most of these battleground states by one
two or three percent and part of the
reason
that he may do that is that if you look
at our next slide on enthusiasm for the
candidates
there is a historic gap between trump
and biden in terms of the level of
enthusiasm the degree of enthusiasm of
this of those who intend to vote
for sure for those respective candidates
and
american political history at the
presidential level tells us
that whether the winner is a democrat or
republican
he has always had the more enthusiastic
supporters um another fact
working in trump's favor is that if you
look at the numbers
in terms of who's voting for or against
a candidate that is
are you voting for joe biden because you
really like joe biden or you're voting
for him because you really don't like
donald trump and what we find
consistently
is a large majority of biden's
supporters are voting against trump
whereas most overwhelmingly by even
larger numbers
most trump voters are voting for trump
rather than against biden
and lastly when we're trying to tease
out the quote-unquote
shy trump voter we ask questions
that relate to how comfortable or
uncomfortable people
are uh letting others friends co-workers
neighbors know who they're supporting
and
nine almost nine out of ten biden
supporters have no problem whatsoever
with other people knowing who they're
voting for but the
overwhelming majority of trump voters
are uncomfortable
eight out of ten are uncomfortable with
others beyond the
most immediate uh family knowing who
they're voting for
and we think that is part of the way in
which
trump shy trump voters are remaining shy
and we
would anticipate that that's going to be
reflected in the final
vote on tuesday patrick thanks uh for
that certainly very interesting so are
you saying that if you go through some
of these factors
uh the trump vote's more efficient than
the battleground states
there's a big enthusiasm gap uh in favor
of
mr trump rather than mr biden people
tend to be
voting against mr trump when they vote
for biden
uh rather than voting for mr biden
himself and there's the shy
trump voters are you saying that your
polling methodology
takes all of that more into account than
the other posters
yes um two examples most of the poll
most the media polls for example that
show these
significant biden leads those pollsters
simply do not
believe except that there are shy trump
voters so they don't look for them and
therefore they don't find them
uh one or two of the other pollsters who
have results closer to ours
they do believe there are shy trump
voters but tend not to incorporate them
in their results
uh to put them into their into their
blender
and to produce their final vote tallies
uh we do
uh we we sort of have a model for doing
that which we used in 2016
uh and so we do account for that which
is why i think that we have consistently
shown trump doing better in the national
popular vote
uh than just about any other poll
of the things that puzzles people
looking at america because it doesn't
really happen in western europe is that
you have posters
that are seen to be allied with
particular candidates or particular
parties trafalgar for example has often
talked about being a republican pollster
so is rasmussen
i mean do you are you regarded as the
institute as a republican pollster
oh well those who don't like our numbers
regardless that way
uh you know we're doing our polls for
the sunday express
in the uk um you know we're non-partisan
uh with a free market in terms of our
think tank status
uh and so our numbers are our numbers uh
but there's no question
that uh there are there is a partisan
lien
uh to some many of the polls i mean what
the
what most of the media outlets do is
they have their polls conducted by
a republican and a democrat um but what
you find in 2016 and again this year
is that the republican pollster tends to
be of the never trump variety
and so again i think that's a that's one
of the reasons
why they don't look for reasons
why or how trump may actually do better
uh than they that their fundamental
assumption uh
you know that they start with in that
regard i guess people are just going to
be suspicious that you're pulling
in a way that's going to give you the
result you want
absolutely i mean it's it's the cardinal
rule of polling you know you
you allow me to choose who my
respondents are and how many of them and
where they're located i can give you any
result you want
so it's it's as much art perhaps more
art than science
although publicly everyone says it's all
about the science but there's a there's
a huge amount of art involved
especially as so few people want to
answer polls
and they are disproportionately those um
those those who favor trump in the
american context
which means it's harder to reach them
and so you either
make an especial effort to do so or as i
think
many of the polls do they simply say
well that's too difficult
i'm going to again fall back on my basic
assumptions
freddie what do you make of it patrick's
polling he's definitely an outlier
um compared to other posters doesn't
necessarily mean he's wrong but
he it is an outlier in polling what do
you make of it
i think it's extremely interesting and i
i tend to be quite skeptical of
pollsters i've learned the hard way um
that they get it wrong and i often think
that the more sophisticated they try to
make their models
uh the worse they get and i'm
particularly interested in this in the
battleground states where
we've been repeatedly told um that the
pulses are now
weighting it differently weighting their
models differently to take into account
non-college educated voters and this
should seem more of a pickup
of trump's support um but i have a
little suspicion that they might have
got that really badly wrong
and i mean if you look at wisconsin for
instance there was a poll out two days
ago suggesting biden is 17 points ahead
in wisconsin i mean i don't think
anybody really credibly thinks that
i think biden's going to win wisconsin
but i don't think he's
uh he's drawing that kind of lead now
speaking of outliers that was an outlier
poll
in wisconsin for sure uh jacob you've
been telling us that mr
biden's going to win comfortably what do
you make of what you just heard there
from patrick
um my question would be
are there moderate republicans
that he would classify as
as biden shy
voters ah
right patrick over to you i mean
yes there are there's certainly going to
be some crosses there certainly
are biden republicans
and i wouldn't claim to have identified
a great number of shy biden republicans
but i'm sure they do exist
i suspect i believe i think that
they will be vastly outnumbered by
democrats crossing over to vote for
trump
and some some of them voted for clinton
some of them will cross over again there
are obama
republicans but what the trump
campaign appears to have been successful
at doing
is pulling out more of the same from
2016 by that i mean
those who either have never voted or
those who hadn't voted for a few
elections so there will be new voters
new young voters new minority voters
which would disproportionately favor the
democrats
but there will be new voters although
some of them will demographically be on
the older side
um so yes both par both and candidates
will benefit
from crossing over and from the shy
voter effect i simply think
that the numbers demonstrate that that
is going to disproportionately favor
trump rather than biden
jacob uh well i
would differ from freddie in that i
think the pollsters have
have gotten a bum rap as the polls
did show the race tightening in 2006.
it was more that you had a will to
believe
on the part of the democratic
establishment
in hillary clinton this the the odds
were that
trump had the 10 13 chance of winning as
the poll showed at the time
and he did in fact hit the trifecta then
and it is possible that this will occur
again but my own
surmise remains that biden's
support is strengthening every day
in this election and the trumps is
eroding and i continue to believe
that biden will have a not a comfortable
victory as you put it andrew
but a smashing one on november 3rd
what what's the evidence that it's um
swinging mr biden's way every day
i think that trump remains biden's
best ally did you i don't know if you
saw any of his rally
last night in florida but again he did
not
emphasize the good economic news of the
last quarter
where you had extremely robust growth in
fact
trump mocked it and said well my
advisors told me to talk about it
but i'm not i'm not going to focus that
i what i really care about are hunter
biden's emails
i do not think that trump is running the
kind of winning campaign that he ran in
2016.
i think the stench of defeat hangs over
him and that
he himself is psychologically trying to
prepare
himself for it kate i was interested in
patrick saying that um a number of
people
voting for mr biden are not really
voting for him they're voting against
donald trump
and i can understand that and see that
that could be a factor
that therefore makes this election we've
talked about this before on spectator tv
it makes this not so much a presidential
election
as a referendum on donald trump
i think it is a referendum on donald
trump though i'm not sure i would come
to the
same conclusion that this works in
trump's favor i think in 2016
in many ways that was a referendum on
the obama administration's eight years
but more importantly hillary clinton
and it turned out that so many people
disliked her as a candidate that they
moved towards
donald trump so it was very recently
that just like of a candidate won
somebody else in election i think that
could be repeated um but i i think
jacob's point
uh is is quite interesting um broadly
speaking
looking at these swing states um i think
it's tightening
in trump's favor i i don't think we
should overlook the fact that
538 nate silver is now blogging about
what happens
if trump wins pennsylvania 538 quite
famously was the closest to getting the
election right
in 2016. i suspect if donald trump had
performed
as he performed in the second debate in
the first debate we could actually be
looking at an
even tighter race but i probably do
still come to the same conclusion as
jacob i i'm not sure it would be
smashing but this is still joe biden's
toulouse donald trump won in 2016 with
about 80
000 votes across three states the
question is can the democrats
take those votes back or bring more
people out to compensate for that and i
suspect this time around they probably
can
douglas you've been traveling around the
states what's your sense what are you
picking up
yes i've been here for the last month
and i've traveled five states so far
um democrat and republicans swing indeed
um
it's very interesting hearing what
patrick says because i do think that
there
this is the the hardest bit to put your
finger on in this race
the most the polls as you say andrew
seemed very clear and have been clear
for a long time
but there is this there is this
underlying question of
the people who wouldn't admit to anybody
that they are going to vote donald trump
i i've spoken incidentally it's like
breaking confidences but the number of
people i've spoken to on this trip
who've told me that they're going to
vote trump but they're not even going to
tell their family uh their spouse
even in one case wasn't to know and
and and and this does sort of resonate
um you notice in it in areas where
you know that the vote is mixed uh but
almost nobody or like one person will
have a trump sign in the neighborhood
and otherwise it's flooded with biden
signs and you notice it with masks you
know they're
in mask wearing aries people are very
proud to wear sort of biden harris masks
you might say that's because the sort of
trump supporters
less likely to be wearing a mask but all
of these things make it
it very hard to guess i mean i think the
other thing that's worth mentioning by
the way is
this whole issue of momentum other than
the polls it's very hard to see what the
momentum
is behind biden because of course
they're not really rallying in any
meaningful sense
the president the other day trolled in
traditional
trump manner the biden camp by splicing
a video of donald trump
arriving at one of his massive outdoor
rallies by helicopter
beside that rather pitiful video of joe
biden coming down
rather too many steps to rather too few
people all sitting in deck chairs
with chalk rings around them and of
course it's easy to
uh to lampoon but it it does put this
it does put this crucial question into
perspective which is
what the underlying message of the
campaigns is at this point
and i think that's something that a lot
of people have missed is this
it's not just about uh um the last four
years
but about what kind of message the
candidates are giving out
now about what america is about to go
through now here's the thing
as it seems to me i went to the trump
rally in pensacola florida
and it it was very striking to me
everything in the atmosphere was
the virus is something we're going to
get over it's not that
bad again you can contest all of this
but this is a claim it's not that bad
we've got to get over it we've got to
not just reopen
but boom we can do it and tomorrow is
going to be great
and by contrast even the presentation of
the biden
events such as they are are these gloomy
worrying terrifying uh
messages of of a really bleak uh
short term now the bleak short term
seems quite likely to be coming
but it does raise this question of just
whether or not people might vote for the
optimistic positive message now i'm not
saying that
the biden camp doesn't have positive and
optimistic messages it does and it's got
a lot of things to be said for it
but this central thing which now
includes kavid within it
strikes me as being one of the things
that people might be missing
patrick has your polling given any
indication of what's been happening in
the final days
do you see things changing things
tightening widening but
what does your polling tell you well
we're two thirds of the way through
our final poll and um although the
numbers are
the date is incomplete uh we're seeing
uh confirmation
of what we've been seeing all along with
that is a very competitive race
um what we have added this time
is we've added several questions about
uh
the alleged biden corruption scandal
uh and that is proving interesting um
number one interesting because given the
almost total uh broadcast media and
major print media blackout on the story
we were surprised at the degree to which
the story has penetrated uh the public
um how the majority of americans
know about it they also know about the
censorship
uh which is interesting and um i'm not
just saying nothing to suggest that
um the answers to our questions uh are
transforming how people are going to
vote however
they are the preliminary numbers suggest
that it is at the margin making a
difference
and making a difference um against
biden now i suspect that that will be
less a case
of an individual changing their
intention to vote for by now voting for
trump but more a case
of giving some trump voters even more
reason in their own minds to show up and
vote
and perhaps depressing the democratic
vote a little bit given that
there is so there's so much enthusiasm
for getting rid of trump it's so little
for putting biden in the oval office
it's just another reason why
an apathetic biden voter may think given
all the polls show that biden's going to
win anyway what does my
vote matter i'm not really into him
anyway and he might be corrupt
so i'm just going to stay home and just
look forward to trump losing
you see jacob i wonder i mean it still
seems to me that this is an election for
mr
biden to lose but if there is any
momentum
uh discountable and it there's certainly
none of what
uh george bush the first used to call
the big mo
but there may be a little more behind
trump in the last uh
week or so the rallies mean they
they've got he's got his mojo back
riley's kind of ignite him he's a
narcissist
he loves all these people cheering he
seems to re-energize him a bit
the latest economic figures he may not
have talked about them but they play to
his strength which has been the economy
mr
biden's fracking gaffe will hurt him in
philadelphia in pennsylvania
and of course we've had riots in uh
western philadelphia pennsylvania
as well and uh i wouldn't want to
overstay it jacob but i think if you add
all that together
there may be a little more behind trump
in the past week
um i don't i don't see it and here
here's the reason why you asked me
earlier
about what was going in biden's favor
you have the cook political report for
example now has texas rated up as a
toss-up
now if biden were to win texas that
would be a smashing victory
and it would be over georgia i mean
biden campaigned in georgia
harris is in texas i think
that the polls in fact may be
underestimating the degree of support
for biden
now the only way we're going to find out
obviously is
on tuesday or in the days after but you
already have
over 80 million people voting it will
take a superhuman effort
for donald trump to overcome what what
appears to be occurring which is a lot
of a lot more young people voting uh
people who didn't vote in 2016 i mean
trump
may be the one person that could
elevate joe biden to the presidency
freddie the there's two ways of looking
at uh
the democrats campaigning in georgia or
texas
one is that they're so confident of
winning
comfortably in the battleground states
that they want to expand the majority
and bring the senate along with them
into
democratic hands i guess the other way
is that mr bynes making the same mistake
hillary clinton made in 2016.
well i do think that there are there are
two ways of reading it certainly i think
i think that the biden campaign has
as much as i can understand they are
beginning to get a little bit anxious
and that's why on monday they've
announced a blitz
in pennsylvania um which a lot of us
think could end up being the really
crucial state
and i'm here now at the moment i i think
just going back to something that um
jacob was talking about i think i have
to agree that the young factor is
something that
uh republican pollsters and and
pro-republican people aren't taking into
account
it does look as though we could be
seeing something of a youth
quake 18 to 29 year olds really coming
out
not because they like biden of course
they don't uh but because they really
really hate trump and they've been
programmed to hate trump
uh for the last four years so i think
that could be a very very significant
factor
patrick is your uh or your polls picking
that up
the youth quake as freddie was calling
it
maybe a reverse quake i mean here's one
thing to bear in mind that hasn't got
enough attention
in terms of the youth vote that is we
define youth votes
19 to 24 which is not exclusively but
heavily dependent upon a turnout
literally on college campuses most
college campuses are
are closed down and so the democrats are
not going to get
aren't getting the press gang effect
that served him very well in
particular you know the obama elections
and
if you add that up around the country
because most of most of the kids who who
were encouraged shall we say to vote on
campus
are not going to vote otherwise
and the votes are going to be scattered
that's depending on who you talk to
a million to two million we think it's
at least a million quote unquote youth
votes that are just not going to happen
for the democrats
i mean that is it not only does it make
a difference in terms of the popular
vote but in terms of who wins the
election
a lot of those college campus towns
depended on those universities
demographically are in midwestern
battleground
states you know we think that's going to
make a difference and i can't say this
out of our numbers but i know
out of a couple of the pollsters who
also see it very comparative to trump
what they're picking up this week is not
a larger youth vote i mean the early
in terms of the turnout youth vote is
down from what the other posters said it
would be
in in the mail in an early balloting but
you're seeing
uh more young voters disproportionately
moving to trump
than was predicted now that may not hold
through election day
but even if it doesn't when you have a
depressed youth vote overall just as
you're going to have
a somewhat depressed african-american
vote
even if trump doesn't do better with
these groups which he is going to do
you're you're looking at mill several
million less
democratic votes so it becomes harder
and harder to see
how they make up those numbers okay well
if mr trump does win again i think we
should all have a
self-denying ordinance never to talk
about polls again
except patrick's because he would have
been proved he would have been proved
right but i think for all the other
posters
i'll just give up on them if they get
this wrong this time
well as was said more than 70 million
perhaps as many as 80 million americans
now have already cast their ballots
either through mail-ins
postal votes as we would call them in
this side of the atlantic or in person
voting early you've been able to do that
on a far
grander scale than ever before because
of covert
the problem is that some states
including some battleground states don't
start
counting these early votes until the
polls have closed on the day
indeed the supreme court has ruled that
pennsylvania and north carolina two
very swing states should count ballots
that arrive
by post even after the election
sometimes by several
days so if the contest is closed in
either of these states it could be days
before
we really know the result there is a
chance that in some key states
mr trump could win among those that
voted on the day more
republicans are thought to vote on the
day more democrats to have done
mail-in or early in-person votes so you
could win
of those that voted on the day and they
can be counted very quickly because
most americans vote by machine and you
can count that quickly
but then start to lose when all the
votes are
counted but he and his army of lawyers
are likely to contest the efficacy of
the mail-in votes
or the early in-person votes and that
could lead to a constitutional standoff
freddie you're in pennsylvania it is the
swing state of swing states
it's also a state that has been uh will
be allowed
not to start counting the early votes
until the polls are closed
if it's close could be days before we
know the result
well indeed i went to an early voting
town hall yesterday and there wasn't a
lot of people the weather was
completely miserable this is this is
another big factor we've got to talk
about the weather has been terrible
uh in pennsylvania if it dries up on the
day that's probably good news for trump
um but there were a few people coming
through and in fact i spoke to
someone at the front desk and they said
it's been like an election day every day
so
they're expecting turnout before the
election to be huge and then turn up and
then even more turn out on the day so
we may be looking at an outrageously
large turnout
and it's the great impossible in this
election because
we we assume it's favorable for the
democrats uh trump talks as though it's
favorable for the democrats particularly
with the late counting
um but there are a lot of experts and
i'd like to know what patrick thinks
who think that it's not necessarily
favorable and that in fact you could
have a republican
surge through early voting and indeed
perhaps through mailings
padre yeah you're right the
most of the polls that have consistently
shown
joe biden with large leads either
nationally or in
on state level uh are basing that in no
small part on a turnout model that
assumes
that we're going to be looking at 20 30
million additional voters this time
and most of the small number of polls
that show the race much closer assume
that there will be more voters but it
won't be
an epic uh chain drastic change
from 2016.
now as you say for the conventional
wisdom is more voters equals more
democrats
and i think that that is technically
true
but i don't think the gap between the
new democrats and the new republican
voters is going to be as great as the
conventional wisdom
suggests or it might have been in recent
years because as i was saying earlier
the republicans what they have this time
they didn't have last time
is they have not only a tremendous
grassroots
ground game but they have arguably the
best
ever it's it's better it's larger it's
more sophisticated than even obama's in
2012.
why why i mentioned that is that they
know exactly
who their voters are and i suspect
they're going to get
almost everyone out one reason i
mentioned that is i think
trump will hit his ceiling he will max
out his vote in the country
biden's ceiling is probably arguably
higher it might be significantly higher
the generic democratic opponent to trump
could get x number of million more votes
but
the democrats for one reason and another
have decided
not to go the ground game route they've
gone the air campaign route with the tv
ads and all the rest of it
that means that i think they are not
going to reach their ceiling so it comes
down in terms of turnout
how much lower than the biden ceiling to
the democrats
uh reach and does trump hit his because
if he hits his and they don't hit theirs
again it's only a competitive race but
one that probably favors him
jacob if you wanted to have
caused trouble over a contested election
the american way of doing things would
seem to be tailor-made to that you don't
count the mail-in ballots
uh until all the polls have closed it
could take you days afterwards so we
don't know
the result uh for several days maybe a
week i saw
the secretary of state from pennsylvania
saying why
do you do it this way it's bizarre
well there are we don't have a federal
system of voting which actually
interestingly makes it more difficult
for for foreigners to interfere
because it's such a confusing system you
know we have
multifarious rules in these various
states it's
it's a it's an utter jumble but it is
tailor-made
for contestation which you had in
in 2000 in florida and
justice kavanaugh in a footnote caused a
stir
when he said that uh mail-in ballots
shouldn't be allowed to flip an election
and justice kagan then responded that
counting ballots
is not tantamount to flipping an
election so yes
if the election is close and
particularly
if it revolves around pennsylvania each
side
biden and trump has already mobilized
armies of lawyers
to go with these questions now my guess
is that trump
you know if it's close and it revolved
around pennsylvania and it wound its way
up the legal system
maybe he would be able to squeeze out a
so-called victory with justice barrett
on the court now but it would certainly
you know further taint both the court
and the legitimacy of the american
political system
my guess i mean it's obvious that biden
is aiming for a knockout blow on
november 3rd
to avoid all of this so that on the
evening of the third
he can say i've won florida we haven't
counted all the ballots in in
pennsylvania yet but i'm the winner of
this election
douglas we we often we're often told
that america the bombs like a tinder box
a dry
tinder box we see the sort of endless
unrest in cities like portland or
seattle
seems to go on forever which was not
true of the riots in 68
for example we've had this new outbreak
in philadelphia we see amazing pictures
of americans trump supporters
also biden supporters or black lives
matter supporters
walking around looking like paramilitary
groups armed with semi-automatic
uh rifles you wouldn't see that in any
other democracy
anywhere in the world if it is a
contested election
how dangerous is it or how likely is it
that that will
manifest itself on unrest in the streets
this is an absolutely crucial question
which i think is on so many american
voters minds at the moment
the number of people in different states
who've told me for instance
that they're going to vote on the day or
vote in advance and then get
out of the city is really quite alarming
uh and in multiple cities i've been told
that
um the places you mentioned uh portland
oregon
seattle i've been to in recent weeks and
yes i mean they've had
nightly rioting and protests for months
on end now
and this is definitely a driver
to a part of the trump base he's very uh
adept at saying to people he famously
with his suburbs comments the other week
which he's reiterated a number of times
he's very adept at saying to people look
you know it's it's
law and order and your home being
protected or
it's the kind of chaos you see in
portland
the thing that struck me in recent weeks
is that some some people have been
asking you know
if if if biden wins uh
are there protests and rights and i i
can't see a scenario really seriously
where there are
if biden wins certainly if he if he wins
very clearly
i think it's a pretty smooth uh
transition
i think that if if trump wins very
clearly
i think there are definitely going to be
cities in this country by the way
they're already advertising for it
antifa blm
have already advertised that their act
they're going to do an activity
on the night of the election in portland
and in seattle
other places will be joining in i think
that if trump wins we'll see that now
here's
here's the worst case scenario though
the worst case scenario
is if it appears on the day that biden
has won
and then from late counts and much more
it turns out to be trump i honestly
think in this city and we're not just
talking about outrider places like
portland here but in major cities like
the one i'm sitting in at the moment
new york i think we're going to see
serious unrest
uh i i can't stress the extent to which
of an outsiders
haven't appreciated this i hadn't quite
appreciated until this trip
the organizational impetus behind these
groups
is really considerable uh they have
their own effectively policing units
they have their own blockading units
just cut off streets
uh when the police step back they step
in as sort of paramilitary organizations
and
run the streets that they're in and
that's aside from just things like the
outbreaking of looting and things
that we saw the other night i think this
country is at the risk of being in
real trouble in the coming days kate
it's your country what do you think
i have to echo douglas and say i'm
extremely concerned
as well i think if there isn't a clear
result on the night or
even worse if both candidates at some
point end up saying that they are the
victor
you are going to have half the voting
population roughly half the voting
population
feeling like this election was taken
away from them and i think frankly it
speaks to the growing power of the state
especially in the wake of coven 19 the
fact that people were forced to lock
down
that on the left and the right people
really do feel at the moment that if
their guy
doesn't win that their lives are going
to be significantly worse often directly
impacted
by who is sitting in the oval office so
yes i am very concerned about it i would
also agree that if joe biden has a very
clear victory
that is probably the scenario where you
see the least amount of fuss i think if
trump has a very clear victory
you're going to see what you've seen for
four years now one of my major
criticisms of the democrats is that they
have tried to push out donald trump
almost in every way
except democracy now this time around
they have the opportunity to do it i
fear if donald trump were to win
that many people still won't accept his
his win as legitimate
um of course if he wins again without
the popular vote in america there will
be even more complaints about the system
itself not just the president
douglas i want to take you back to
portland again because i know you've
been there i've
i'm puzzled i mean normally riots peter
out in the end that's been the
experience
of riots in the united kingdom or in
europe and even in america
until now but important it seems to be
never ending they seem to be going on
almost if not riots
unrest going on every night and
and yet the mayor of the governor of
oregon they don't
seem to do much about it how i mean have
they just given up on part of the city
uh why is there no political penalty uh
for this because in this country there
will be a huge political penalty to pay
yes that's that's one of the striking
things about uh
i'd say not just portland but seattle
but portland's the sort of ground zero
on this one and
here's the thing i mean you can see you
can see the troubles in
a city like new york at the moment the
same troubles we've got in all of our
cities in london everywhere else
uh businesses have gone out of business
uh um
boarded up shops and much more but you
can't help
thinking in a city like new york well
it's been through ups and downs before
and it'll come back you know the even
with the uh
even when there's lawlessness in new
york there was a little bit the other
night
that new yorkers won't put up with this
and they'll vote in at some point
soon a mayor who's for law and order and
a bit more and a bit stronger on all
that
and stronger on backing the police and
tougher measures and much more
the thing with portland is that such an
outlier
is that there's there's actually a
memorial election coming up
the mayor who's been totally ineffectual
and actually just last month had to move
out of his own apartment block because
antifa were rioting outside it and he
he fled his own home and still won't do
anything about it
he's got one contender against him for
the mayoralty
who's a woman who is an open supporter
of antifa
so here that's the problem for
portlanders
is that they've got a man who's
ineffectual and a woman who supports the
paramilitary groups
and and uh you know this is a as you say
andrew this is a very
unusual situation in a in a democracy as
for where the momentum comes from it
comes back to a couple of things that
people have already mentioned
one is um uh people whipped up into i
think
hysterical and catastrophic uh ideas
about the nature of the society they're
in
uh um another is simply that in the wake
of the lockdowns and much
more this is something for a certain
type of person to do
they get meaning they get a sense of
purpose
they honestly think that if they pull
down enough things and there's not much
left in portland to pull down by my own
observation
but if they pull down enough things
they'll kind of
get to this fair equitable society that
they dream of i mean there's no such
thing of course
they're just going to continue to
immigrate their city and chase more and
more people out of it
but it is this lack of willingness on
the part of the governor
and of the mayor to for instance
and the d.a i should add by the way
that's the most shocking thing for a
british viewer
that that an elected d.a a highly
political figure
decides not to prosecute serious crimes
carried out by rioters
is why they get into this situation you
can go and smash a lot of stuff up
including smashing people up
in uh in oregon and nothing happens to
you
and that's why it's still going on are
plain folk in
uh portland voting with their feet just
getting out
yes uh it's uh it's just i can't stress
enough i tried
in the magazine last week in my report
from portland to stress this but you
know
i think a lot of people even in america
but especially outside america
would be genuinely shocked by the state
of this city
and there are other cities in a similar
situation seattle the area formerly
known as chas
is just boarded up shop after boarded up
shop
and a tent city sitting in the middle of
what used to be one of the attractive
parks of the place
the homelessness problem by the way
that's the same in l.a
there are these massive problems uh uh
which
frankly whoever wins the election
for the white house has to find some way
to address
it seems to me as an outsider utterly
shocking that you can have an area like
downtown portland which has been
entirely handed over to the homeless
where every single municipal building
like all others is
covered in in smashed windows boarded up
windows
graffiti no business is gonna come back
to this place
and it's it's a real disgrace to america
of course if i can just say so
the reason also it's it's been in some
way left
to rot like this is and i i do
stress that of course the president did
try to send in federal guards earlier in
the year to deal with this
but to some extent the reason why
portland has taken on the significance
it
it has is because it looks like a sort
of exemplar of
what happens when you defund the police
and and pull back law enforcement and do
all of the things that the radical parts
of the left want to do
it's become something like a sort of
lesson to the rest of the country
it's terrible for the poor people who
live in portland because there are many
decent people who just want to live in a
safe city
which isn't immiserated like this but to
some extent it has
understandably become something like a
lesson
to the rest of the country you know if
if you go that way
this is what it looks like patrick what
does your polling uh
tell you the there was a lot of
references out in the campaign to how
mr nixon in 1968 uh following the rights
then made law and order the
the big issue uh
the looking back on that came this
campaign mr nixon made more of it than
mr trump
has uh i guess partly
mr nixon was the challenger then mr
trump is the president i mean you could
see law and order cutting both ways on
the one hand
in these democratic cities it seems to
have broken down on the other hand you
could say well hold on you're the
president
um you've done something about it how is
it playing
it's played to donald trump's favor
we've been polling on this since the
minneapolis
uh violence started and uh the trump
campaign have exploited leveraged what's
been going on and how and why
as douglas has so sort of insightfully
summarized
uh and so they've done a lot of
advertising uh
they've done a lot of their grassroots
outreach has been on this
and one of the we've asked one ques one
of the questions we've asked on this
issue throughout
is do you think president trump's
response to the violence and the riots
and the looting
has been just about right or do you
think
it's been um too harsh or
you know too strong or not strong enough
uh pluralities
throughout the months have said it's not
been tough enough
right um and not everyone but enough
americans uh except trump's argument
you know he says crudely if you know if
you if you if it was up to us you know
give us half an hour an hour this thing
will be over and naming you know fill in
the blank in terms of the city and the
troubles
um enough americans accept the argument
this is a problem that mayors and
governors should do something about and
that
trump really has to be invited in and
so so far it's playing very well for him
and it's cutting across in in ways that
help him
you see gun sales are through the roof
right
40 percent of the new handgun sales are
to women
uh 68 into african americans
so these are folks who never dreamed of
having a firearm in their house
never and and there's no better
predictor of someone voting republican
than being a gun owner
and so you you have for example some of
those suburban
women white and black who were looking
at biden very seriously some of them are
now looking at trump in a way they never
thought they would that is favorably
not because they like trump they still
hate him and they hate his tweets and
everything
all the rest of it but they they don't
think that biden will keep them safe
and safety is an issue personal safety
and security is an issue
that trump is successfully sort of
wrapped around himself
and contrasted with biden because biden
has for most of the time being a wall
just sort of
sitting besides beside the issue and his
running mate hasn't been helpful because
certainly earlier on she was
figuratively cheering on
cheering on the protesters and the riots
i noticed uh mr biden was a rather uh
quicker to condemn the writing in uh
west
philadelphia the most recent ones a few
nights ago jacob are you
surprised by just the longevity
of this urban unrest in certain cities
because it is very different from
previous writing in america whether it
was
in the 60s or even after rodney king in
los angeles other ride the warts riots
as well they flared up they were very
violent often more violent than they've
been
but they then died down again this
hasn't happened
yeah i have been surprised by the
perdurence
in portland of the uh what what sort of
resembles a paris commune but
if there has been any immiseration
as douglas suggests i think
the the lion's share of it has proceeded
from
president trump's own unwillingness to
confront the pandemic which has
essentially
delivered a body blow to the american
economy but the radicals
constitute a noisy and vocal fringe and
the more room you give them
the more they'll take i think the
initial
mistake of some of these mayors was to
back off
from confrontation now here in
washington dc interestingly enough
there has not been a real upsurge
of violence since after lafayette park
the uh the mayor of washington actually
has taken
a surprisingly hard line
and uh i i don't see a problem here
i don't think that the left wing uh
antifa
ultimately will amount to a hill of
beans if biden wins if trump remains
president it will it will serve as a
useful foil for him
and it will be interesting to see where
it all goes it could
then then you could see some some some
further violence
douglas quick response then we'll move
to our final item
just quickly i i agree with a little bit
of the latter
part of what jacob said which is i mean
antifa are desperate for trump to win
uh um they will still keep going to some
extent if biden keeps going
but they what they want most is trump to
win because then they think they've got
even more reason to keep attacking
policemen and assaulting federal
buildings and destroying the cities that
they're in
just one thing about that on the
immigration point
i stress that first of all the situation
in portland and i say seattle for
instance
long preceded the pandemic i mean this
this was a city where you could openly
assault
and hospitalize a journalist that you
thought was negative to antifa
and nothing happened you know and that
was before the pandemic that portland
got to that situation where these
paramilitary groups
could hospitalize journalists and the
state viewed it with equanimity
and the second thing is of course is
that what i just described is
particularly bad in portland as it's
particularly bad in seattle i mean the
businesses that won't return
but frankly we can see that in
absolutely every city in the world at
the moment it's the same in london it's
the same in lots of other places a
number of businesses
that are just going under is everywhere
so the thing that seems interesting to
me
is does the american voter recognize
that the
the immigration brought about by the
covered thing an extra layer on top of
these other layers
is something that everybody is going
through or do they think it's something
that america is uniquely
or worse than anyone else going through
and if so do they blame that on trump
and i think that is one of the big
questions in this election because
as i say the the covet issue is
something that is
global and whether or not the public see
that
and credit that their president has done
what he could or not
will dictate a lot in this election i
think all right well we're almost there
to polling day the u.s presidential
election however is not a race to win
the popular vote if it was mr trump
would have lost in
2016. it's a race together majority in
what's called the electoral
college which allocates places to each
state roughly on the basis of population
now you need 270 places on the electoral
college to win
that takes you across the winning line
florida has the third most places
in the electoral college it's third
equal with new york's california first
then
texas then florida new york even stevens
it's a swing state
unlike new york and it will report early
on the night
so all eyes will be on the sunshine
state if joe biden wins florida
he's almost certainly heading for the
white house if mr trump holds it
if we won it in 2016 it doesn't mean
he's won four more years but it does
mean he's still
in the race he then needs to win
pennsylvania michigan and wisconsin
and at least two of these on most
polling
two of the three don't look great for
him but you can't rule anything out
freddie tell us a bit more of how you'll
see the night unfold
on the night of the third of november
well as as as you say andrew i think all
eyes are on florida
and as i understand it we hear a lot
that florida's counting system
is very very efficient and even with all
the early voting it will be very very
efficient so
you may around 5 pm eastern time you may
have
exit polls from some
from some pro-trump counties in florida
or
counties that voted for trump in 2016.
and
if they show large trump margins we're
talking 20 30
um margins in favor of trump then you
might be
thinking it we reasonably suggest
florida might go trump's ways if it's so
so
if trump's just edging it that suggests
biden has a real shot at florida
and i think everybody agrees i'd like to
know if patrick agrees
if biden takes florida it's it's
curtains for trump
if trump then wins the sun belt we then
look up towards
michigan wisconsin pennsylvania at the
moment it looks like bishop michigan
and wisconsin biden has them um ohio is
another interesting one but i think
trump's
team think they have ohio so again the
question becomes pennsylvania
and interesting minnesota is an
interesting one where trump has really
got some momentum in the last few days
so that could
change things around but i think if
trump wins the sun belt
so across the south we're looking at
pennsylvania as
the key the key state here early in the
evening florida is important because
it's on the east coast it's an east
coast
time it it
is one of the states that does count the
mail-in votes and the early in-person
votes before
the polls close so they think very
quickly after the polls close at eight
o'clock
on the night florida will be able to
merge the on the day
voting with the early voting and give us
a
reasonably clear picture of what will
have happened that's why
all eyes will be on florida early in the
evening uh patrick mark our card for the
for the night what should we be looking
out for as the results come in
i my largely agree with everything that
freddie just said
i would add minnesota once it gets the
midwest minnesota is the bellwether
biden has to keep minnesota trump has an
excellent chance if minnesota goes to
trump
it's a very good chance that wisconsin
and perhaps michigan do as well
i would look earlier in the night at new
hampshire it's only four electoral votes
but like minnesota narrowly won by
clinton
the trump campaign's made an enormous
effort biden hasn't even visited new
hampshire did very poorly as he has
always done in presidential primaries
there
there are a lot of independent minded
voters in new hampshire
if trump is to win this election and win
independence new hampshire may tell us a
fair bit about that
the other thing to look at be later in
the night if this is still close
arizona and nevada in the southwest
arizona trump in 2016 has been trending
democratic as
has nevada which is uh was a clinton
victory both look like they're going to
be
quite close you could see either
candidate winning both of them i suspect
trump is going to hold arizona and may
take nevada that'd be what may be one of
the surprises of the night
because there are no casino unionized
casino workers in nevada anymore
and there aren't any students either
sorry there's also
there's quite a lot of concern um in the
democratic party that they haven't been
messaging well enough
to hispanic voters about how to fill in
the ballot
and there's a lot of concern that a lot
of democratic votes in nevada are not
going to count
that is in terms of hispanics and
african americans looking at
the overall talents the dem forget the
top line
in terms of the demographics if trump is
out doing 2016
in terms of african americans and
hispanics then it's going to be a very
long night for joe biden and perhaps a
short successful night for trump
well if it is a long night as you say
all eyes
will move west to maricopa county which
is the greater phoenix area
it used to be where they just weighed
republican votes there they didn't have
to count them
the demographic change has now put it
into contention so that will be
very interesting to see uh cake glitch
are gonna ask you all
on election night what are you gonna be
doing it used to be
there were parties everywhere in london
the biggest one was in the american
embassy if you were lucky enough
to get invited not for people like me
because i have to work on election night
but uh there were lots of places to go
to watch the results coming in what are
you going to do now
well let's hope nothing too fun because
i think it would probably be
illegal under the uk's current tiered
restrictions
i'm going to be drinking a lot of coffee
and i'm going to be preparing
to be surprised jacob mentioned at the
start of spectator tv tonight that joe
biden thinks that allowing donald trump
to speak
is one of his best assets and this was
actually confirmed in a book from
evan osnos recently published a
biography on joe biden it seems that the
biden team
uh would agree with jacob's analysis
just let donald trump get out there
that has the the power to sway minds and
hearts against donald trump
but i am totally prepared to see some
upsets in donald trump's
favor i think as we spoke about before
the fact that the biden campaign
seems to have been ignoring similar
states that hillary clinton ignored back
in 2016
could suggest that it comes down to a
few thousand votes again
um so i'm i'm preparing for it to go
either way andrew
okay uh douglas where are you going to
be on the night
i'm going to be in dc um at the heart of
things
as much as one can be at the heart of
things legally in this era
um yes when i arrived into california
the other week a friend of mine said to
me
douglas this trip of yours in the states
it's it's disaster tourism isn't it
uh you're like those people who go to
north korea in a bus party
and i i said i said it's true to some
extent anyhow the point is
is that if it's the end times or
something like it and the ultimate
disaster then i want to be at the very
heart of it
very well patrick where will you be i'll
be in dc
bouncing around and i'll either be
bouncing around with a
sense of self satisfaction or with a
sense of shame
written all over my face well certainly
some posters
are gonna have a sense of shame all over
their face that's for sure jacob
i will be here in the heart of the swamp
complacently hoisting a bumper of
champagne
as i watch to see for me the only
question is
can can biden crack 400 electoral votes
if uh uh perry's the thought for you
jacob it was mr trump what would you
drink then
um i would be flabbergasted but probably
want a uh a stiff macallan i still yeah
you probably would need a
single malt scotch indeed in the 18 year
old i would recommend for you freddie
you'll be pulling together all of
spectators american coverage
of the election as it unfolds where are
you going to be doing that
i'll be in dc as well um and if uh
if it's a controversial trump victory i
will go out on the streets and join the
rioters
uh and then when i get through it
observe i hope
freddie to observe you need to stress
yes exactly
by law and order uh but if it gets too
scary i'll run to jacobs and drink
whiskey with it
yeah if he's opening the mcallens then
you should certainly go to him
and i know you'll all be watching uh the
results coming in on
bbc one bbc news channel and bbc world
because i'll be presenting them and uh
if you're
if you're not you could be in trouble
because there'll be a test afterwards to
make sure
you're watching the right results show
that's all we've got time for
just a reminder if you want to hear more
from spectator journalists
uh of the time we have on this program
subscribe
at spectator dot co dot uk vote
just one pound a week and once you're
there
tell us who you think is going to win if
you're right you get a thirty pound
amazon voucher you cannot lose really at
one pound
a week and the chance of a thirty pound
amazon voucher as well maybe
after tonight's discussion you've got a
better idea of who's going to give you
that 30 pound
voucher anyway that's us when we come
back
next week we will know who the next
president of the united states is
at least i think we will but maybe we
won't bye
you